For years you have asked,
"Where is...
the yearly bottle flip challenge?"
And we have finally answered!
Behold my challenger:
JackSpediceyPie!
I have been summoned! *giggles*
You've been there all along?! \0o0/
I know you keep me in the basement...
*Ding-Dong* My door is ringing.
*giggles*
He really does keep me in the basement.
Please.
Help me.
Please, you guys don't know what it's like...
It's been years.
My hair isn't even green anymore,
the dye ran out.
I didn't grow this beard on my own,
it's just cuz I haven't been able to shave in so long.
God, please help me, please send help.
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING THEM!!!
Nothing.
Bottle Flip Challenge.
Stop clapping at everything
I clap if i want to
We have our bottle
We have our g-fuel
G-fuel in the bottles!
It's (time), have you been practicing?
No
I've been in your basement I can't!
Oh that's right
I haven't even been able to drink water
Well that means ur gonna lose Jack
Dammit!
U suck Jack!
dAmMIT
reddit FiftyFifty
Oh no we bottle flip, whoever lands the bottle, the other person has to look at the reddit
That's right.
This is the most requested video on my channel, here we are: Bottle Flip Challenge 2K19.
The annual
*dab*
Annual bottle flip *laughing*
C A M E R A   TWO!!!!
*laughing*
btw the legs are animated well
K.
this is my bottle, I will flip this.
*fails*
Ok well thats
*laughing*
Get out of the way Edgar.
Edgar.
Edgar's the judge
*fails*
UOAH
OAHHHHHH
*DOUBLE DAB*
HAHAAHAHAHAH
NICE TRY!!!
NICE TRY!!! I KNOW I DID THAT  LAST TIME AS WELL
HAAHAHAAHAHAH
*continues laughing*
CAMERA ONE!!!
pewds: i dont wanna do that
man decapitated in tropical forest
or a hedge hog in a kayak
oh please
jack: please be the hedge hog in a kayak
please kayok in kyac... kayock???
* everyone laughing*
jack: kayok in kajack!!?? ahahaha
yay!!! *claping*
awwwwwwww!!! hes cute
thats adorable
thats a risky clip of the day!!!
hey its not that there is a decapitated man behind him or anything
ayyayyayyayy!
what you wanna see it?
uhhhh
wait a minute look at * jack interfering*  doggy!!!!